16 listes frontissent engagés dans les
Yvelines et à l'issue du premier tour
plusieurs d'entre elles en position de
se maintenir c'est le cas tout d'abord à
Rambouillet le secrétaire départemental
du Front national totalisant 9% des
suffrages exprimés Philippe Chevrier qui
réalise là un score légèrement plus
élevé que celui qui l'avait enregistré
lors des législatives en 2012 mais le
meilleur résultat du Front national dans
le département est à chercher du côté de
Mantes-la-Ville le candidat du
Rassemblement bleu marine arrive en tête
avec 21% profitant de la division de la
gauche et sans doute de la contestation
des électeurs dans une ville où le
chômage est important on le sait
évidemment le Front National a fait ça a
effectuer une mue assez importante une
espèce de normalisation du moins en
apparence
et quand on souvient de ce qu'était le
Front national en local quand on se
souvient de la façon dont le Front
National a géré les communes auxquelles
il avait accédé
du type Toulon Marignane etc voilà
ça avait été un échec absolu dans les
communes où le scrutins c'est joué en un
seul tour la formation de Marine Le Pen
à d'ores et déjà acté son entrée dans
l'opposition de plusieurs conseils
municipaux comme à Élancourt ou les 7,5%
de Nicolas Bauer lui suffisent pour
obtenir un siège même cas de figure à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux pour Sylvain
Grison avec ses
9,4%, et à plaisir pour Alexandra Nicoli
et ses 9,3% à Versailles François
Siméoni disposera de deux sièges des
passants tout juste les 10%, un score
qui l'imaginait sans doute plus
conséquent mais qui s'explique par la
multiplication des listes proposées aux
électeurs aujourd'hui les électeurs ont
fait un choix qui est de dire bon ça
suffit maintenant on a essayé un coup à
droite un coup à gauche
un coup les deux un coup droit de gauche
un coup un président à droite une un
premier ministre à gauche etc on a tenté
toutes les combinaisons avec les parties
dit historiques
bon bah ça ne marche pas on va tenter
autre chose rappelons qu'en 2008 le
Front national n'avait présenté aucune
liste dans le département